In the first case when we used the local implementation and used only the remote
interface. The implement that makes instances of
the object remotely accessible. So the heavy lifting
needs to be done by the implementer.
That's not quite preferable. One virtue of the
local implementation is that the service provider can
make selected servers visible to the selected clients.
So that's the only virtue that one can
associate with the first implementation that uses local. You
cannot make a hard case, a strong case
for this choice. So this choice where we are
extending remote object and the remote server. We
are letting Java RMI do all the heavy lifting
to make the server object visible to the
network lines. And that's the more preferred way of
building a network service, and making it available for clients anywhere.